im august 2020 zerstört eine massive
explosion den hafen und ganze stadtteile
von beirut dabei verlieren fast 250.000
menschen ihre wohnungen und häuser
rund 100.000 kinder werden obdachlos am
dienstag wird in linz hörsching eine
weitere hilfslieferung in einer hercules
des österreichischen bundesheeres
verladen
das bundesheer hilft seit der
verheerenden katastrophe wo es kann
sofort nach dieser explosion unsere
unterstützung auch angeboten wir haben
auch einen astra soldaten bereits am
folgetag als experten für die
internationale katastrophenhilfe in den
libanon entsandte er war teil eines
zwölfköpfigen koordinations starb es der
uno ja und wir sind jetzt am heutigen
tage daher wirklich ganz besonders froh
dass wir wieder helfen können dass wir
heute beim transport der hilfsgüter für
über hunderttausend kinder unterstützen
können und vier tonnen schulmaterial und
haltbare lebensmittel werden nach beirut
geflogen organisiert von der obfrau der
hilfsorganisation altes for children der
real geht diese hilfslieferung auf die
beine gestellt hat für sie nicht das
erste mal mit partnerorganisationen
hatte schon mehrere solche liefen
organisiert die haben nach tonnenweise
warme kinderbekleidung schuhe hefte
schulsachen mal sagen dass die
transportkapazitäten der c- 130 nicht
voll ausgeschöpft werden hat einen grund
die überstellung der hilfsgüter passiert
ja im rahmen eines versorgungs fluges
das heißt es ist auch möglich für
slowenien zb etwas mitzunehmen und wir
können die organisation die ngo artist
von children hier unterstützen mit vier
tonnen an so wichtigen materialien sei
es lebensmitteln oder auch
unterrichtsmaterialien für
hunderttausende kinderbetreuung
ohne die hilfe des bundesheeres wäre
diese hilfslieferung erheblich kleiner
ausgefallen erklärt schade ich hätte
natürlich dann müssen tausende euros
wahrscheinlich für die logistik zahlen
das wäre sozusagen etwas gewesen dass
ich den kindern aus dem mund nehmen
hätte müssen und was mir sehr schwer
gefallen wäre
und deswegen bin ich umso dankbarer und
find's einfach großartig was ich bisher
hier leistet